c'est au conseil constitutionnel que se
jouera en plein coeur de l'été le
dernier espoir institutionnels des
opposants au pass sanitaire validé sur
les chapeaux de roue le 25 juillet par
les sénateurs et les députés le texte de
loi qui encadre l'utilisation du pass
sanitaire doit tout de même être
examinée le 5 août par le conseil
constitutionnel
confiant le premier ministre avait
annoncé qu'il saisirait lui-même
l'institution n'en doutez pas notre
objectif comme toujours a été de prendre
des mesures proportionnées à la
situation sanitaire garantissant les
libertés publiques fondamentales et
assurant le développement de la sécurité
sanitaire de nos concitoyens outre le
premier ministre
74 députés principalement de gauche ont
saisi l'institution
voilà c'est fait on a défendu les
libertés individuelles et collectives
devant le conseil constitutionnel le
gouvernement fracture notre société sans
être efficace contre le coc vide pour
macron la seule variable d'ajustement
face à la pandémie ce sont nos libertés
le conseil constitutionnel est souvent
le secret de décision surprenante on va
dire il est quelquefois peu prévisibles
en revanche s'il ya vraiment des
arguments qui se pose en termes de
libertés publiques parce que on est là
sur une atteinte véritablement massive
et peut-être que la première question
que devra essayer de se poser conseil
constitutionnel c'est comment se fait-il
que ce régime d'exception dure aussi
longtemps
jusque là ce qu'on a vu c'est que il
était plutôt dans l'acceptation d'un
état d'urgence au nom de l'urgence
sanitaire
trois semaines après les déclarations d'
emmanuel macron sur l'extension du pass
sanitaires qui ont mis le feu aux
poudres
le mouvement d'opposition s'amplifie en
france selon les chiffres très
controversé du ministère de l'intérieur
le nombre de manifestants qui battent le
pavé est de plus en plus important alors
même que l'été est d'ordinaire la
période creuse pour les manifestations
et dans l'opinion publique de plus en
plus de personnalités issues d'horizons
parfois très différents refuse ce
dispositif pour un grand nombre
d'opposants à ces mesures il n'y a rien
à espérer des autorités qui même si
elles sont désavoués par le conseil
constitutionnel pourrait recycler d'une
manie
à ou d'une autre les dispositions du
pass sanitaire pro il n'y a qu'une
chance de faire reculer le gouvernement
la pression maximale dans la rue et la
rue ils ont déjà prévu d'y retourner